okay hurry up man you were fierce she
went all crazy on him shouting that's my
boom bah they said this was gonna be
better and Goku's grande training under
we begin I am so ready for this
aah a lot of you pointed out in my last
video that Lex was the man behind one of
my favorite childhood voices dr.
neocortex from the crash bandicoot
series however it doesn't matter how
amazing the voice actor is when the
script and direction is bad then there
is little that can be done to raise the
overall production at least from a voice
acting perspective anyway
well yes Lex that's a great idea why
don't I go through each character in the
showing you know tell you what I think
about cold unlike the first season I
endured
I managed to get my hands on every
single excruciating second of bang zooms
Dragon Ball super season two or as I'm
going to affectionately refer to it as
resurrection F off
last time I reviewed bang zooms battle
of Claude's Ark and so I thought it was
time to finally put this dub to bed I
don't think it was renewed for another
season so let's start with something
good this okay I'm now under the bed I
am so ready for this all right fine
there were some actual good voice acting
moments in this season of baby Buddha
most notably with these select
characters Wiese go on Hercule Bulma and
vados I'll focus on the first three
episode 15 the first episode is arc
featured a lot of her Q and genuinely
unthankful that did Jameson price
honestly has a really good voice for
Hercule and actually allowed me to get
into the story something I never thought
I'd say for bang zoo entertainments
Dragon Ball super dub waves of wicked
power emanated forth from his muscled
body wheeze isn't bad either taking a
lot of influence from the Funimation
cast clearly so big props for dog air
holds for doing a pretty good job of
voice something that allowed me to again
get into the story of the show which I
really appreciate considering I had
about five hours worth of resurrection
app off to watch today so now that I
think about it he did have a few weird
moments
[Music]
however the real hero of this dub has to
be Chris Hackney and he plays
Gohan okay we all know that go on for
the majority of super got a pretty raw
deal but that doesn't mean this guy
doesn't do a great job of voice and
Gohan you're very sweet Gohan but I told
you this morning I can handle making
dinner nonsense it's fine my job is to
keep you safe and happy while the little
ones still growing in there okay he
sounds very natural and comfortable in
the role which was unexpected coming
from a show whose main character sounds
like this shouting I genuinely think
this could be my favorite version of
adult Gohan something about his voice
just sounds so youthful and clear not
that I don't enjoy Kyle Harbert from
Funimation's version I mean I love that
man more than words can wield the matter
but I have to give it to Chris Hickey
for her surprisingly good portrayal of
Gohan
[Music]
Oh Nicolo ha Goku
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I mentioned in my previous worst dub
video that Shawn Chimel mentored Lex
Lang for the role of Goku Shawn informed
me on Twitter that this did not happen
so there's that straightened up while
Lex might be a highly competent and very
successful voice actor that direction
will kill any performance in its wake
and so Goku still sounds really awkward
I mean I can see what he's trying to do
like the other voice actors he's trying
to emulate his Funimation counterpart as
best he can
but for some reason he just ends up
sounding like another thing you might
notice while watching this is that Goku
never changes the tone or the volume of
his voice it's like he's stuck in this
never-ending cycle of cracking puberty
voice which is the most grating thing
you'll ever listen to on your TV uh I
keep trying to tell her that the kid's
gonna be totally fine with all that same
blood but every time I opened my mouth
she shouts at me to get outside and sit
my butt on this tractor however well not
nearly as offensive as the Battle of
quads arc there are times where that
classic awful delivery still creeps it
and Coco's grand training under Wiest
begins I am so ready for this that's not
even the half of it dotted throughout
this production there are these weird
audio mistakes
the most obvious one being this if you
can sense his power level then you can
teleport right to him Krillin you are a
genius
I didn't notice any of this in season 1
particularly so I will give bang zoom
the benefit of the doubt here it's
probably just the crappy recordings I'm
working with they are in four by three
aspect ratio after all for the first
half of this season Vegeta still suffers
from the same thing that plagued his
character in the last one that problem
being he sounds like a fan doing an
impression of Christopher Sabbats Vegeta
to whom I love and adore it's very
breath Ian's overall comes across as
force to me however that doesn't carry
on throughout the rest of the arc as
many of you already know episode 18 of
Dragon Ball super could be one of my
favorite episodes at anything Dragon
Ball period so needless to say I was
eagerly awaiting bang zoom his rendition
of it for better or worse and honestly
it wasn't that bad at all we began to
sound more natural and Vegeta you know
stopped soundly like a bad impression
although it was still a bit breathy for
my taste no that may be the last happy
thing you ever say why don't you turn to
Him now and run back to earth before
things get too rough for you on the
other hand Goku was hey man if you're
just scared to compete with me I promise
I won't rub it in your face when I win
no chance you can't top me well he was
doing his Goku thing and you know the
whole thing wasn't that bad all things
considered it was actually all going
really well until Frieza came so much
different than I am invited
this is how it feels to be reborn yeah
he's a for lack of a better term [ __ ]
again very breathy and impressionistic
nothing offensively laughably bad just
boring but it did definitely take me out
of the story your every condescending
work deals my hate anything to take my
revenge so in this section the voices
are pretty bad and really silly sort of
like the animation in this section who
said that
he'll reprimand you you can't you can't
you can't diss draggable supers
animation how dare you you can't draw
with that said while the men voice in
freezer isn't laughably bad his
performance apps any sense of authority
and occasion the freezer character has
it's hard to describe but in bang zooms
rendition it he just sounds like another
henchman which one could argue is worse
than laughably bad depending on your
point of view well it wouldn't do to
keep them waiting
aside from those guys there are a bunch
of minor offenses also like this awkward
delivery of the title card for episode
16 the Jeter gets a transistor
oh wait Krillin sounds like he's about
17 years old here seriously
you face down quite a few challenges in
your day but I bet not a single one has
been as tough as this is it's nowhere
near as bad as the first act but in
reality that made it 10 times harder to
watch the first arc I reviewed was
off-the-wall bananas with
mistranslations and writing mistakes
while seeming like it was directed by a
cocker spaniel and honestly that was
kind of the charm of it all this rules
from laughably bad - yawn fully below
average no I don't know about you but
I'd much prefer to watch say the room
over a Batman vs Superman book you fight
me so I guess you could say this season
of Dragon Ball super was bang doomed
from the start
with that said I will appreciate that
while bang zoom entertainment got off to
a truly special start they cross the
finish line with a borderline
forgettable blemish on their books one
that I'm sure they thought would vanish
soon after from the public memory but
that'll do it for this week guys catch
you next week thank you so much for
watching
[Music]